okay welcome back everyone so today
we're gonna solve ordinary differential
equations using Laplace transforms on
Friday we're going to start looking into
control systems which are awesome and
then on Monday we're going to do a
little bit more on partial differential
equations okay so the fourth homework is
due on Friday the fifth homework will be
due next Friday and the fifth homework
will cover Laplace transforms ordinary
differential equations and it'll
probably cover a little bit of Monday's
lecture okay because I want you to have
some practice before the final cuz I'm
definitely going to ask you about
Laplace transforms and PDEs on the final
okay any questions about what we were
doing with Laplace transforms last time
anything at all so we are typically
integrating a signal from a fixed
initial time to infinity to do the
transform and so we assume that this
signal is kind of developed at at the
point we take the transform so why don't
we do some examples and get a feeling
for what you can and can't transform
maybe you can give me an example like
what would you be thinking of that it
would not be electrical signals right
series typically to ensure stationarity
through spectral coefficients or
spectral transformations of the signal
we will do something called maximal
voluntary contraction which is an
isometric contraction that transforms
the signal into stationery for
even a penalty so I was wondering if the
same principles apply to us yet so we're
generally assuming that we have a signal
that you know starts at some time so
it's kind of boring beforehand then it
evolves
something to infinity there are times we
can break this assumption and make kind
of a generalization for window data or
time series data
but that's a little more complicated
okay so so last time we derived what I
think is the most important property of
the Laplace transform and this is
basically directly inherited from the
same property of the Fourier transform
which is if I transform the derivative I
just get my Laplace variable times the
Laplace transform of the function so if
I have Laplace transform of F prime of
let's make this up time T then this is
going to equal my Laplace variable s
times my Laplace transform function f
bar but now because we're integrating
from 0 to infinity I also have this
initial condition
- my initial condition F at time 0 ok we
just derive this last time from the
integration by parts so if I want to do
the Laplace transform of f double-prime
how do I do that what's the first step
this is you can just say that this is
DDT of some function G of T where G of T
is DDT of F of T right so I can just do
this in two stages I can say okay well
this is going to be s times the Laplace
transform of F prime minus F prime at
time 0 and what is the Laplace transform
of F prime well it's all of this stuff
so I just plug this in and I get that's
s squared times the Laplace transform of
F minus s times this is minus F 0 yep
minus s times F 0 minus this term here
so I'm just doing like a nested it's
kind of almost like a chain rule I'm
just doing nested it applause transforms
of derivatives and I get this expression
here that makes sense that we just
plugged in Laplace transform of F Prime
in here and in general if I have the
Laplace transform of the nth derivative
with respect to time then I'm gonna get
a big polynomial in s I'm going to get s
to the power n times F bar times the
Laplace transform of F minus s to the
power n minus 1 times F of 0 minus s to
the power n minus 2 times the first
derivative F prime of 0 minus dot dot
minus s times the n minus second
derivative of F evaluated at 0 minus the
N minus 1 derivative of F evaluated at 0
so superscript here just means I'm
taking the derivative that many times
this isn't too hard to show that if you
just keep going down the line this is
the form you get okay the upshot is all
of these are just numbers these are my
like these are values of my function and
my derivatives it's kind of like a
Taylor series expansion right I got a
bunch of derivatives and a bunch of
evaluations at zero so I have a big
polynomial in s and this is the only
term that has something interesting my
Laplace transform and okay good
and last time I was a little bit
careless and I think I wrote that these
were evaluated at zero plus and that's
not right these are evaluated at zero
minus which means these are evaluated at
just to the left point of t equals zero
so if I had if I had something like a
step response at time zero then my value
of F at zero minus is equal to zero
and my value of F at zero plus is equal
to one because this thing essentially
jumps you know epsilon to the right of
zero it's 1 epsilon to the left of zero
at zero and we want to be using this
value this F of zero minus value for all
of these derivatives that we're
evaluating okay there's some reasons for
this
they're good reasons they're kind of
philosophical reasons you want this to
be causal and so you can't know what's
going to happen epsilon from now you
have to you can only know what happened
epsilon a wave behind in time okay so
these derivative formulas are extremely
useful for solving ODS extremely useful
so just I'm gonna ask this every time
because I can't remember anything how
many of you have used Laplace transforms
to solve Odie's before
not okay good so you probably haven't
seen the kind of general way that I'm
going to go about doing this for control
system so this will probably be new fur
for a lot of you okay so what we're
going to do is we're going to revisit a
relatively simple example that we've
looked at before which is the spring
mass damper system and just to refresh
your memory we have some fixed wall and
we have a spring damper and some mass
EMA and we're interested in the position
of this mass as it's moving back and
forth based on Newton's second law so we
can say that the equations of motion are
MX double dot plus CX dot plus KX equals
0 and if I introduce some new
coordinates if I introduce the natural
frequency and the damping ratio this is
just review we've totally done this
before okay if I introduce these two new
variables then I got a really nice form
of the equation X double dot plus Omega
naught C X dot plus Omega naught squared
x equals 0 so why do I like writing this
in terms of Omega naught and C they're
physical parameters what do they mean
physically
right so natural frequency Omega and
damping ratio Zeta so what this means is
that I can vary these independently and
if I just vary Omega not and that
changes the frequency of oscillation and
if I independently vary theta then that
makes it damp more or less quickly it's
more or less damp with data so these
kind of separate the two effects and if
you like to think about this in terms of
the eigenvalues of the characteristic
equation theta would be the real part of
the eigenvalue and omega nought would be
the imaginary part this is how fast the
sines and the cosines move and this is
how much exponential decay I have this
is just a review we've done this example
before in 564 but now I'm going to show
you that you can solve this really
really easily using Laplace transforms
ok so I'm going to essentially pick some
numbers to make this system just have
numbers in it so we're going to use X
double dot plus 5x dots plus 4x equals 0
and what other information do I need to
make this a well-posed ordinary
differential equation in the show
conditions how many do I need so the
second derivative I'm gonna have two
different e to the lambda T's and
they're each going to have a coefficient
and I need two initial conditions to
determine my two initial conditions make
you unknown coefficients yeah so let's
just pick really easy ones that make all
the maths work out nicely ok good so
this is the differential equation we
just picked some Omega naught and some
Zeta I think Omega naught is U and Zeta
is 5 over 2 okay so now we're gonna
solve this using Laplace transforms the
first step is I'm going to Laplace
transform each of these terms X double
dot X dot and X okay so just everyone
help me what is the Laplace transform of
X dot doubled-up
s squared times X bar of s minus s times
X not minus X dot nots this is just a
little pause transform of X double dot
so I'm going to put brackets around it
okay plus five times the Laplace
transform of X dot s X bar s minus
x-naught okay plus four times the
Laplace transform of X which is just X
bar all of that equals zero so I want to
color code this just because it's a
little easier to understand when we
color code this is the Laplace transform
of X double dot this is the Laplace
transform of X dot and this is the
Laplace transform of X of T so all I've
done is just Laplace transform both
sides if I multiply by a constant
remember my Laplace transform is linear
so if I look lost transform this term
plus the number of times this term plus
the number times this term it's the same
as Laplace transform of this plus five
times the Laplace transform of this plus
four times little plus transform of this
because it's linear okay just like the
Fourier transform because it is the
Fourier transform essentially the
generalized Fourier transform okay great
so now what would be the sensible thing
what are we trying to solve for in this
equation X bar right X bar is
essentially my solution but in the
frequency domain so I want to solve for
X bar and I'm going to inverse Laplace
transform it so let's just collect all
of my s bar stuff on this side so I have
s squared plus 5 s plus 4
I have all of that times X bar and then
I have everything else everything else
that doesn't have an X bar I'm going to
put on the right hand side so I'm going
to say that this equals and all of these
terms that don't have an X bar I'm just
going to move over to the right hand
side and I'm also going to plug in
numbers at this point because X naught
and X naught dot are numbers okay so I
have a 2 so minus 2's I'm gonna bring
that over and I got a plus 2's and then
I have a minus minus 55 is plus 5 and
plus 5 times a minus 2
okay so plus 5 and minus 10 is minus 5
I'm gonna bring that over and get a plus
5 if I do that again was that super
confusing I'm just I'm evaluating this
this is minus minus 5 is a plus 5 and 5
times minus 2 is minus 10 so plus 5
minus 10 is minus 5 I added to both
sides I get 2 s plus 5 the reason I'm
belaboring this is because I totally
messed this up in my notes this morning
and got really really confused okay so
now this is kind of amazing we have a
few really interesting things happening
here so first of all what is this
expression on the left hand here this is
the characteristic polynomial of this
differential equation right remember if
I plugged in X of T equals e to the
lambda T if I just made this assumption
and I plugged it into all of these terms
then I would get a characteristic
polynomial lambda squared plus 5 lambda
plus 4 equals 0 and the solutions of
this characteristic polynomial would be
my eigenvalues okay and so this is my
characteristic polynomial which is great
and the characteristic polynomial is
responsible for telling me everything
about the dynamics of this OD it tells
me what all the time skills are what all
the lambdas are so all of the dynamics
are over here on this side and all of my
initial conditions are on this side so
all of the information about my initial
conditions is on this right-hand side
right because every term that was left
over that didn't have one of these X
bars was in terms of my initial
conditions and I just brought them all
over to the right-hand side so now I
have a polynomial in my initial
conditions in terms of my initial
conditions and I have a characteristic
polynomial on the left-hand side so this
is starting to look kind of interesting
okay so what's the last step I need to
do
all right so yeah we'll have to inverse
Laplace at some point but that's another
step down the road what's what's before
that yes I want an isolate X bar so I
divide by the pop of the characteristic
polynomial so I'm gonna say okay X bar
is now equal to 2's plus 5 divided by s
squared plus 5s plus 4 and now what I
want to do is I want to inverse Laplace
transform this thing right this is my
solution this is the solution to my
ordinary differential equation with
those initial conditions but it's in the
frequency domain so I have two inverse
Laplace transform to get this back to a
function X of T but how do I inverse
Laplace transform we didn't want those
kind of horrible and we only did it for
a very simple expression so we did we
know that the inverse Laplace transform
of 1 over s plus a is equal to e to the
minus 80 this is all we know this is the
only inverse Laplace transform we know
because we actually derived this one
when we were doing complex analysis so
what I'm gonna try to do is split this
polynomial up this rational expression
up into a sum of first-order monomial
fractions this is called partial
fractions this is how everyone solves Oh
des using Laplace transforms so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna say well
this is really equal to some stuff over
s plus 4 times s plus 1 now this is
starting to look a lot like how we solve
Odie's right we're taking our
characteristic polynomial we're
factoring it into monomials each of
these are my eigenvalues minus 4 and
minus 1 are my lambdas and what we're
going to say is I want to write this as
some constant a divided by s plus 4 plus
some other constant B divided by s plus
1
and I want to find what is a and what is
B because I know how to inverse Laplace
transform each of these okay so how do I
do that we say okay so if I have two
fractions and I want to add them
together I take a times this denominator
plus B times this denominator divided by
both denominators so this is a s plus 1
plus B s plus 4 divided by s plus 1
times s plus 4 and so what we have is
that this numerator has to equal this
numerator and so I'm going to solve for
the a and the B that make these equal
okay so let's just do this so we have a
times s plus 1 plus B times s plus 4
equals 2 s plus 5 and I'm going to
collect all of the terms of s's and make
that an equation and I'll take all the
terms with ones and I'll make that an
equation so I have a plus B equals to a
s plus B s equals to s and I have a plus
4 B equals 5
and now I can solve for a and B pretty
easily so how would you do this what
would be the easiest way to solve for
this yeah I'm gonna subtract one of
these from the other one let's subtract
1 from 2 so I get 3 B equals 3
that's convenient B equals 1 and if a
plus B equals 2 and B is 1 then a is
also equal to 1 and so this thing equals
1 over s plus 4 plus 1 over s plus 1
okay the final step is now we have X bar
of s equals one over s plus one plus one
over s plus four and I'm going to
inverse Laplace transform this and the
great thing about Laplace transforms is
that they are linear so the Laplace
transform of this is equal to the
Laplace transform of the first term plus
the Laplace transform of the second term
so we have X of T X of time this is what
we want we want a real solution in time
is equal to the inverse Laplace
transform of X bar of s and that's equal
to the inverse Laplace transform of this
plus the universal plus transform of
this and we know what each of these are
we know that this first one is e to the
minus T and the second one is e to the
minus 14
okay so that's the solution of our OD
now you might be thinking to yourself
this doesn't seem a lot simpler than
solving this using the characteristic
equation and either the lambda T and
that's certainly true this is a lot of
steps involved in solving this but there
are a number of reasons why this is a
really really good way to solve Odie's
and i'll tell you a number of these
reasons so first of all are there any
questions about the general procedure
okay anytime I have a linear system a
linear system ordinary differential
equations I will always have my
characteristic polynomial on the
denominator I'll always be able to
factor it into S Plus lambda 1 s plus
lambda 2 s plus lambda 3 I'll always be
able to factor it into these monomials
and inverse Laplace transform each of
them almost always if you get into a
nastier situation like you have a
nonlinear differential equation you're
trying to inverse Laplace transform you
would try a lookup table or Mathematica
okay so other questions about the
Laplace transform yeah function here
right hand side would be transformed
that follow through so this is why we
want to be doing things on the little
claw strands form domain because I could
add a forcing function U of T and I
would just Laplace transform it and I
would just have a u bar and this would
be my numerator plus u bar and
everything would look the same except
now I'd have a u bar divided by
characteristic polynomial so that's what
we're gonna do in the end of class and
on Friday so that is one of the key
reasons why we want to be working in the
frequency domain because even though
it's harder to solve an initial
condition problem it's much much easier
conceptually to add forcing to add
control so that's something we'll visit
in a little bit it's also really nice
because working with this function in
the frequency domain gives us a
tremendous amount of insights about what
the physical system is do
so on Friday I'm going to spend most of
the time telling you how to gain insight
from looking at that solution in the
Laplace transform domain so for example
this is s can be any complex number
right s can be I Omega or v plus I Omega
or whatever this can be any complex
number you want for s and so this is a
complex valued function with a real part
and an imaginary part and those real
parts and imaginary parts have extremely
relevant physical intuition for almost
all physical systems for materials for
fluids for elastics and vibrations and
and we're gonna get into why we care
about this function on Friday ok so even
though solving the OD e and getting the
time-domain solution might be a little
hairier it's still good to go through
this intermediate step because it
simplifies how we understand the problem
ok should I do another simple example
would that be helpful yes ok let's just
do a quick one this one's from Voisin to
prima it's even easier and we can go
pretty quickly
okay okay so the boys DePrima example is
also a second order differential
equation that's just X double dot minus
X dot plus 2x sorry minus 2x equals zero
with initial conditions X of 0 equals 1
and X dot of 0 equals 0
so we can solve this one super easily
let's just go through it what are all of
my solutions what do i do first
each of these I get s squared X bar
minus s X not minus X dot not minus SX
bar minus X not if I mess up please tell
me -2 X bar equals 0 okay next step
collect all my X bar terms my solutions
on one side so I have s squared plus s
squared minus s minus 2 times X bar and
all of my initial conditions I'm going
to bring over to the right hand side so
that equals plus 1 s s X dot is 0 this
initial condition is 0 so I'm just going
to forget about it and then minus minus
1 when I subtract it over gives me a
minus 1 okay so I've collected all of my
dynamics terms over here my
characteristic polynomial and these are
all of the terms that fell out for my
initial conditions okay next step
tonight that's bar of s equals it's a
function of s it's s minus one over s
squared minus s minus one minus two good
and what is this factored into so what
do I know right off the bat from that
this solution is gonna be gonna be
unstable so this is going to be a stable
eigenvalue this is an unstable
eigenvalue so right off the bat i know
that anytime this thing has a
denominator 0 thats in the right half
plane positive two this is bad news
ok good and finally i'm going to write
this as a over s minus two plus b over s
plus one okay so let's solve for a and B
well we have a times s plus one plus B
times s minus two equals s minus one
so a plus B equals one that's just the
esse terms and then a minus 2b equals
minus one
I'm just equating all of the real all of
the non s terms okay so I'm going to
subtract the bottom from the top and I'm
going to get three B equals two which
means B equals two-thirds and a equals
one-third okay so my solution X bar of s
is equal to 1 over 3 times 1 minus 1
over X minus 2 plus 2 over 3 times 1
over s plus 1 and now finally I'm going
to inverse Laplace transform this whole
thing and I get X of T equals 1/3 times
the inverse Laplace transform of this
plus 2/3 times the inverse Laplace
transform of this numbers just pop out
so this is 1/3 each of the 2t plus 2/3 e
to the minus T so it's actually not that
complicated it's pretty straightforward
if you're going to solve this using the
traditional methods it might be a little
easier just to plug in e to the lambda T
and solve the characteristic equation
but then at some point you're still
going to have to solve for the initial
conditions for the coefficients and it's
it all ends up being about a wash
okay any any more questions about how to
how to solve this okay let's do the
general case so this is kind of
remarkable even though the actual by
hand steps might be a little more
complicated what's remarkable is that I
took my differential equation and when I
Laplace transform it I turn all of the
differential equations and rates of
change in calculus into essentially an
algebraic equation my solution is just a
polynomial divided by another polynomial
this is algebra so we've taken calculus
and turned it into algebra by doing the
Laplace transform this is a huge
simplification even just conceptually
it's a good simplification and this is
going to make it so that we can actually
solve PDE s that we couldn't solve by
hand before okay so the last thing I'm
going to do is show you the general case
all right so let's say that I have a
really high order differential equation
like X nth derivative plus some
coefficient times the n minus once
derivative plus dot dot plus a 2 X
double dot
a 1 X dot plus a 0 equals 0 ok what
information do I need to make this a
well-posed ordinary differential
equation with a solution initial
conditions so what initial conditions do
I need I need all of the N minus 1 to 0
derivatives of X technically I could
have any equation any linear equation in
those being satisfied I could have a
whole equation like X dot of 0 plus X 0
equals 2 and it could be really nasty
but I'm not going to do that so let's
say that my initial conditions look like
this
okay so this is a well-posed ordinary
differential equation with a solution
okay we can solve this using normal
methods no derivative but there is an X
good thank you okay so the first step is
that we have an ordinary differential
equation the second step is that we're
going to Laplace transform everything so
I'm just recapping what we've done for
the simple case but for the more general
case okay so we take the Laplace
transform of both sides and we get
something like s to the N X bar - dot
dot minus B and minus one plus a and
minus 1 times s to the n minus 1 X bar -
dot dot dot minus BN minus 2 plus dot
dot dot plus a1 s X bar minus b0 plus a
naught X bar equals 0 all I'm doing here
is I'm just taking the Laplace transform
of each of these X derivatives and I'm
plugging them in where those terms go
and I'm writing a lot of dot dot dots
because I don't want to think about
what's between them okay so this is you
know applause of the nth derivative of X
this is Laplace of the N minus 1
derivative all the way down to Laplace
transform of X dot and X
okay good
so what's the next step let's step three
combine all the sbar terms and put all
of the initial condition terms on the
right-hand side okay so I have
step three is essentially combine all of
the X bars and then put all of the
initial condition terms on the
right-hand side so we're gonna have
something like now how how do I know how
all of the X bar terms are gonna combine
how do I do this really really easily
what's the characteristic polynomial so
it's just s to the n plus a n minus 1 s
to the n minus 1 plus dot dot plus a 2 s
squared plus a 1 s plus a naught X bar s
equals okay this is just collecting all
of the X bar terms is going to give me
the characteristic polynomial in s times
all of the X term X bar terms and then
this equals everything else and I'm
gonna say that it's a polynomial in s so
it's a poly in s with coefficients given
by the A's and the B's and really this
codes up all of the initial conditions
okay so all of the dynamics of my
differential equations forget about the
initial conditions for any initial
condition my differential equation has
some dynamics e to the lambda T's that's
all on the left-hand side and all of the
information about the initial conditions
is on the right-hand side in fact every
term on the right-hand side its
coefficients are directly in terms of my
initial conditions B's and so I'm just
gonna call this some Polly of s and it's
parametrized by A's and B's this is just
shorthand notation I've introduced
because I don't wanna keep writing down
this polynomial cuz I don't know what it
looks like it's a nasty polynomial I
might ask you to write this down on a
homework that would be a reasonable
thing to do because it actually turns
out that the form of this polynomial and
initial conditions is quite interesting
and
up a lot in mathematics it's a very
useful matrix it's called like well it's
got a name okay
all right so what's the fourth step okay
so why am i dividing let's let's be more
clear why am i dividing by the
characteristic polynomial I'm isolating
my solution okay so I want X bar of s
equals this polynomial P of s
parameterize by a and B parametrized by
my initial conditions divided by my
characteristic polynomial s to the n
plus a n minus 1 s the N minus 1 plus
dot dot plus a 1 s plus a not my
characteristic polynomial in the
denominator okay we're getting
SuperDuper close only two more steps
okay what would you do at this point
before I do partial fractions what do I
do
okay so you're both right in my notes
I've essentially skipped steps and then
tried to read just a Phi them so what we
do now is we break this up into a
partial fraction of factors of the
denominator so we factor the denominator
into all of our eigenvalues all of our
lambda 1 lambda 2 lambda 3 's all of the
roots of this there are n roots each of
those as a lambda and I'm gonna write
this as some coefficient 1 divided by s
plus lambda 1 plus some coefficient 2
divided by s plus lambda 2 plus dot dot
plus C n divided by s plus lambda n and
the missing step here is that
essentially I factor the characteristic
polynomial into S Plus lambda 1 times S
Plus lambda 2 times dot dot times S Plus
lambda N
so I break it up into n monomials these
are given by the end roots of this
characteristic polynomial things go
really badly and get really weird when I
have multiplied it when I have when I
have the same root multiple times and it
gets a little complicated but let's not
think about that for now it's not
terrible it's just a little more
complicated you have to it's actually
easier in Laplace transform then in the
time domain because we can solve this
with the Laplace transform okay and so
the last step is step 6
so I also don't I don't just want to
factor into the polynomial I also want
to solve for C 1 C 2 dot dot C N and
this is the method of partial fractions
okay so what's the last step now that I
have X bar in this wonderful simple form
of a sum of monomial fractions what do I
do inverse Laplace and this is actually
easy to inverse the plus because I know
what all these terms are so X of T
equals C 1 e to the minus lambda 1 T
plus C 2 e to the minus lambda 2 T plus
dot dot plus C and e to the minus lambda
and T and that's my solution
okay so the general form you can do this
for any ordinary differential equation
that's linear it becomes super simple if
you do this for a non-linear OD e where
do you think you'll get stuck let's say
transform some really nasty horrendous
OD e like X dot X double dot plus x
squared equals coasts of X so I can
certainly Laplace transform every term
in here maybe forget the coast of X
let's just make this a zero make it
easier yeah so essentially everything
goes bad starting at step three and that
gets really bad in the partial fraction
step so I could take and write you know
s X bar minus X naught times s squared X
bar minus X minus s is it X dot X not
minus that is a dot not plus X bar
squared equals zero but now I can't just
solve for all of the X bars on the left
hand side
I don't just get some polynomial and F
times X bar I have X bar Squared's and
other X bar squared and everything is
super complicated okay not to say it's
impossible to solve I could solve for X
bar equals some square root of some
polynomial in s but how do I inverse
Laplace transform that's it I can't
write this as a nice sum of easy
fractions right so it gets more
complicated but it is possible in
principle to do some of these things so
I don't want you to think that Laplace
transforms are limited to just linear
ordinary differential equations they're
not
okay questions about the general form
before I go on a little bit farther your
system would you then to simplify to do
a linear linear exit about in some
neighborhood and transform it before
computers people still wanted to solve
these problems and so they wrote
gigantic books on how to solve the
inverse Laplace transforms of these
nasty functions for common differential
equations like this that are popular
that pop up all over the place for beams
and for elastics and drum membranes and
optics and all kinds of common nonlinear
differential equations there are entire
books of how to solve these Bromwich
integrals to inverse Laplace transform
and they're all coded up in Mathematica
and so it turns out there's actually an
amazing wealth of techniques to solve
these things what you can often do is
you can often write this as a product of
simple things you can inverse Laplace
transform and then the inverse Laplace
transform will be the convolution of all
of those terms what we'll find on Friday
is that even for really nasty hairy
problems we can still do inverse Laplace
transforms numerically sometimes so even
if I don't know how to inverse Laplace
transform something I can still do it
numerically a lot of the time okay other
questions
okay I have just a couple more minutes
so I'll tell you a few more things so
the next thing I'm going to tell you
kind of motivates what we're going to do
on Friday which has already been alluded
to which is the nice thing that one of
the nice things about the Laplace
transform solution to OD ease is that
it's very easy to add an external
forcing term without really messing up
anything so it keeps it very clear
what's happening in the notes for 564 I
did write down the solution for external
forcing one time and it was a little
complicated in terms of a convolution
integral and we'll see that it basically
is much easier in the frequency domain
so if instead of my ordinary
differential equation equaling zero
let's say I have it equal U of T some
external forcing this is the basis for
all of control theory to have this
external forcing U of T here where I can
actually force my system and make it do
something I want now I still need
initial conditions and I still go
through the exact same steps I Laplace
transform and I get the same thing s
squared plus 5 s plus 4 times X bar of s
and it equals all of the terms in terms
of my initial conditions which I think
was 2's plus 5 but now I also have the
Laplace transform of my forcing term
plus u bar of s ok so these are all of
my initial conditions and this is my
forcing and so now I can say that my
function X of s X bar is equal to my
original part my homogeneous solution
with my initial conditions 2's plus 5
divided by my characteristic polynomial
but now I have an additional particular
solution given by U bar of s
/ s squared plus 5 s plus 4 the great
thing about Laplace transform solutions
is that if I inverse Laplace transform
this I still get the homogeneous
solution to my initial conditions and I
also get this additive term due to
forcing it and we're gonna see that this
is the convolution of my forcing with
something interesting which is the
inverse Laplace transform of the
characteristic polynomial ok so this is
just kind of leading up to the lecture
on Friday we're gonna start right here
and we're gonna start seeing what this
term does to the differential equation
in terms of this very special one
divided by the characteristic polynomial
so we'll even give it a name we'll say G
of s equals 1 divided by the
characteristic poly is my transfer
function okay we're gonna start looking
at the properties of this transfer
function why it's useful why it's much
easier to write my differential equation
this way with forcing and we'll be able
to do cool things like design this u
function to make this system look more
like what we want so we can design a
control strategy u that stabilizes an
unstable system like a pendulum or does
all kinds of other cool things okay
that's it for today Friday we'll talk
about this system with for soon
you